hello and welcome back to the point
sorry for the wait I just needed some
time to myself you know time to to think
to get my head straight to try and
figure things out
life can be exhausting with emails and
phone calls and Twitter and Donald
[__] Trump so every once in a while I
just need to disconnect you know the
feeling right we play games for lots of
reasons for entertainment for a
competition to play with friends to meet
new ones or just to pass the time but
why we play games has as much to do with
personal preference as it has to do with
personal circumstance we often play
games because of the realities of our
lives chances are if you have kids you
don't play many mm oats if you don't
have a job you probably play a smaller
amount of games more frequently and if
your brain is tired after a long day's
work you might want to play something
that lets your mind relax modern life
can be tiresome it's not work it's
School relationships mortgages updating
your apps taking out the trash life is
the ability to become a never-ending
list of responsibilities that pile on
top of each other one after the other
every once in a while we all just need
to take a break you walk the long way
home go for a drive or look at something
pretty for a while Media also allows us
to means to do this to rid ourselves of
the burdens of this mortal coil and
explore new worlds via books films
Netflix binge watches and video games so
today I want to talk about those places
we go to lose ourselves not the games we
play to win or to finish the story or to
get better the games we go to disconnect
when I get home from a hard day's work I
usually reach for a game that doesn't
tax my brain too much that used to be
playing a few games against the AI in
FIFA but the past year it's mostly been
rocket League a game I can happily play
a few matches off
it helps me settle into my evening
routine what game is it for you perhaps
it's Madden or destiny maybe you pop
into the division for 30 minutes or do a
few laps in Forza
we all have our own crutches and from
either games can help us relax after a
hard day but then there are games which
whether through design or happenstance
allow us to totally cut ourselves off
from our world for hours on end
you've got straight up meditation em ups
like journey dear Esther and Abzu but
I'm talking more about those games that
act like a sort of a digital walk in the
woods you know games that wrap us up in
an environment and allow our brains the
space to breathe for all the time I
spent closing hell gates breaking into
people's houses and selling drugs to
cats there was also plenty of downtime
in Oblivion there's no way of knowing
for sure but I bet I spent half my time
in Tamriel just wandering the landscape
paths ran like octopus tentacles from
the Imperial City outward into forests
along streams and deep into mountains
exploring these paths was incredibly
pleasurable to my mood being away from
busy civilization and instead enveloped
by beautiful nature with a soothing
orchestra made ambling down beaten pads
and addictive activity even exploring
yet another ayleid ruin with their damp
echoing chambers was more calming than
creepy oblivion was a game packed with
action but like Skyrim after it it was
also a game where you could lose
yourself on a solo walk that level of
immersion in nature felt as close to a
calming amble among the pines as video
games have ever gone but it's not the
only game that allows for that sort of
solo introspection
Red Dead Redemption is a game about
being alone with the land john marston
spent the majority of the game on his
own away from his family trying to solve
his problems like going on a drive to
figure something out red dead redemption
is Marsten's journey to contemplate his
issues just stretched out over weeks of
time and thousands of miles and while
the action in Red Dead is explosive and
exciting these moments of downtime
whether had spent hunting exploring or
simply getting from place to place are
just as powerful so much of the game is
spent trotting along dirt roads with
little to look at or do but the mood
that these moments strike with big skies
and vast rolling landscapes allow you to
sit back and enjoy the moment which is
really something else considering just
our boring this should all be on paper
it demonstrates so much of how our brain
works that we yearn for these moments of
quiet solitude to relieve mental tension
if quiet solitude is good for our brains
and that explains why I find fall out to
be so therapeutic
whatever your wasteland of choice these
landscapes while containing pockets of
activity are mostly empty
in fact even more than empty they're
filled with the ghosts of previous
activity roads homes playgrounds and
Industry that once was life here has
been pause allowing you to tiptoe in
quiet contemplation I'm no psychologist
but often when talking to friends about
depression long playthroughs of the
Fallout games are cited as a coping
mechanism whether it's the game's reward
loop the sympathetic mood at strikes or
the fact that you spend most of your
time walking around on your own fallout
is clearly a game which allows our
brains and intermission to unknot itself
so many games allow us this sort of
mental downtime whether it be the
quieter moments of your favorite RPG
playing around in create mode in
Minecraft or just wandering the world in
skates there are many games that allow
us the space to let our subconscious
wander so while we're on the subject of
space and allowing our subconscious to
wander
you may remember the last few episodes
of the points were about hype mystery
and how many people were setting high
expectations over what no man's sky with
setting itself out to be well nat itself
we know exactly what type of game this
is or at least I think I have a decent
idea
no man sky is the woods of Tamriel it's
the plains of Mexico it's a lake in
Minecraft the capital wasteland a
downhill road and skate no man's sky is
the quiet part of every game you've ever
played stretched out over an entire
galaxy it's a game that's played by your
subconscious a game with objectives so
loose it's crying out for you not to
follow them a narrative that's whispered
in your ear instead of shoved down your
throat or conversations with aliens are
brief confused and hazy like a half
awake dream it's a space travelling game
that isn't focused on galactic politics
or allegories of race but instead plays
with themes of motivation life direction
and the purpose of faith you spend
practically all of your time in this
game just wandering floating from planet
to planet looking at vistas viewing
wildlife listening to music waiting 50
seconds to reach a planet this is the
most boring game I've ever played and I
can't stopped playing it because like so
many of the places I've just talked
about it's so often what my brain needs
simply put no man's sky is a game about
listening to yourself
and while no man sky has loose goals and
mechanics that plot some degree of
progress your direction in this game is
heavily dictated not by what you are
told to do but what you want to do this
isn't some stripped-down version of
elite a game that's crying out for more
mechanics it's a dream like choose your
own adventure book being played by your
subconscious what motivates you wealth
connections with others forward momentum
do you need the universe to be a happy
accident or intelligently designed does
faith make you stronger and how long
will you chase an answer before turning
back these are the questions that no man
sky is asking you at every step you take
and I'm not just talking metaphorically
these are choices that actually manifest
as you progress on your journey yes on
the surface the combat is very basic and
there's an incredible amount of
repetition but there's something deeper
happening here while some games dabble
with allowing you to be alone with your
thoughts this game is an exercise in
solitary contemplation one that's
happening
even if you're not totally aware of it
when we play video games were usually
alone most games try and obfuscate this
fact but no man sky is a game where this
fact is inescapable the universe like
our brains is an infinite plane so often
it's bombarded with Gold's
responsibilities relationships problems
to solve we all need to take the long
walk home every now and again to stare
at something beautiful to enjoy an
introspective walk in the woods no man's
sky is that walk in the woods the game
that holds a mirror up to the player and
shows them who they really are and much
like the walk in the woods by the time
you've stepped away from this universe
and returned to normal life hopefully
you'll have learned a little bit more
about yourself
you